[Musique]
mais chiocca coup je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté de participer à notre
émission c'est un grand plaisir de vous
avoir très heureux d'être avec vous nous
avons beaucoup de choses à aborder car
pour nous vous êtes l'un des grands
esprits de notre temps
chaque jour de nouveaux gadgets
apparaissent chaque jour il y a des
petites découvertes mais il n'y a pas eu
depuis des années de percée majeure en
physique qui nous aiderait à comprendre
de manière générale comment fonctionne
le monde
qu'est ce que cela implique cela veut-il
dire que nous sommes arrivés à la limite
de ce que nous pouvons réellement
découvrir en physique à part de ses ex
of the world
non et non je crois que nous commençons
à peine à explorer les mystères de
l'univers
le prix nobel a été récemment décerné
pour la découverte des ondes
gravitationnelles et nous espérons
mettre des détecteurs d'ondés
gravitationnelles dans l'espace un
nouveau type de télescope un télescope
gravitationnelle pensez-y
aujourd'hui tous les télescopes utilise
la lumière désormais il nous utilisons
la radio pour contempler les trous noirs
à l'étape suivante
il y aura des télescopes
gravitationnelle qui nous permettront
d'observer des trous noirs à l'instant
même de leur formation
ainsi une nouvelle ère dans l'astronomie
va commencer avec les détecteurs donc
gravitationnelle à partir d'une
découverte faite il ya seulement
quelques années
pouvez vous nous parler de ce prix nobel
et des physiciens qu'ils ont reçu pour
leur découverte des ondes
gravitationnelles
qu'est-ce que cela signifie ce renouveau
bientôt en mesure de contrôler la
gravité comprenez c'est une question qui
m'intéresse
[Rires]
nous ne pouvons pas contrôler la gravité
mais jamais nous pouvons la mesure et
l'exploiter et pénétrer certains des
plus grands secrets de la nature
qu'est ce que cela va apporter aux êtres
humains
tout d'abord on comprendre à l'origine
de tout comment l'univers a été créé
les gens se posent la question suivante
s'il y avait eu une explosion au début
des temps d'où vient cette explosion
quoi l'univers ressemblent et il avant
la jeunesse nous autres physiciens
croyons que l'univers est une sorte de
bulle
il est en expansion c'est la théorie du
big bang cependant nous pensons qu'il
existe d'autres bulles
d'autres bus l'univers constituant un
multi vert donc au lieu d'une seule
bulle de savon l'univers s'étend et nous
vivons dans une bulle de savon dans un
bain de bulles de savon qui sont autant
d'univers et nous pensons que quand ces
bulles entrent en collision le big bang
peut avoir lieu
donc cette expansion cosmique qui a eu
lieu au début des temps peut arriver
suite à une collision d'univers on peut
être à cause de la fission d'un univers
en deux univers plus petit nous allons
mettre dans l'espace peut-être dans
quelques décennies un télescope
gravitationnelle qui nous permettra
d'observer le moment de la création
nous allons obtenir des photos de
l'enfance de l'univers contempler
l'instant de sa naissance et peut-être
trouverons-nous les traces d'un cordon
ombilical un cordon ombilical reliant
notre univers enfant à un univers mer
c'est peut-être en cela que consiste le
big bang que nous y serons nous un jour
en mesure de concevoir le temps et de le
contrôler si nous avons une meilleure
compréhension de comment fonctionne la
gravité est bien un jour d'ici quelques
millénaires nous aurons peut-être assez
de puissance à notre disposition pour
commencer à penser à construire une
machine à voyager dans le temps ou à
mettre en place une distorsion espace
temps comme on voit dans les films
j'allais vous vous posez cette question
là c'est un rêve chimérique de
l'humanité ou une question qui se posera
à l'avenir après c'est chimérique pour
nous parce que nous sommes encore
primitif
cependant il est possible que dans
l'espace lointain d intelligence
extraterrestre est déjà accompli cela
mais déchiré l'espace-temps exigerait
une énergie équivalente à celle d'un
trou noir
les équations d'einstein accepte la
possibilité de voyager dans le temps par
exemple
einstein a dit que le temps était une
rivière qui s'accélérait
et ralentissait mais cette rivière peut
se diviser en deux ou disons il peut y
avoir des tourbillons qui rendrait
possible un voyage dans le temps nous
n'en sommes pour l'heure pas capable et
je pense que dans un avenir lointain si
nous avons assez d'énergie peut-être que
nous serons en mesure de distordre le
temps et peut-être même de faire un trou
dans l'espace temps c'est ce qu'on
appelle un trou de ver beaucoup de
théorie nous aide à mieux comprendre
comment fonctionne l'univers
vous avez contribué à l'une des
principales c'est la théorie de chant de
cordes
si je comprends bien en substance c'est
une théorie qui imaginent que le monde
est composé de différentes corps
d'énergie et cela signifie t'il que dans
un sens nous ne sommes rien d'autre que
de la musique d'un orchestre à cordes
oui c'est ça nous pensons que la
multitude de particules subatomiques que
nous avons des centaines de particules
subatomiques qu'on obtient en brisant
des protons à genève en suisse ne sont
que des notes de musique sur une
minuscule cordes qui vibre un électron
un neutrino est un quark ne sont que les
différentes vibrations d'une minuscule
corde de violon
qu'est ce que la physique la physique
n'est rien d'autre que les harmonies que
vous pouvez créer avec ses cordes
qu'est ce que la chimie la chimie ce
sont des mélodies que vous pouvez jouer
sur ses cordes
et qu'est ce que l'univers l'univers est
une symphonie de cordes
alors quel est l'esprit de dieu dont
albert einstein a parlé pendant les
trente dernières années de sa vie
l'esprit de dieu est la musique cosmique
qui résonne dans tout l'univers
c'est ça je cite l'esprit de dieu au
sujet duquel albert einstein a écrit
c'est pour ça que beaucoup de gens
disent
hermann hesse on fait aussi mentionne
dans un livre si je ne m'abuse que la
musique est bien plus que tout autre art
ah il est impossible d'expliquer comment
elle peut affecter les âmes
la musique peut faire pleurer les gens
et elle n'a pas besoin d'être traduites
parce que c'est ce que nous sommes
pensez à tous les paradigmes de la
nature
lequel d'entre eux est le plus riche par
exemple certains estiment que les
orbites constitue peut être le paradigme
de la nature mais vous ne pouvez pas
créer beaucoup de systèmes solaires avec
des objets qui tourne autour d'autres
objets mais penser à la musique la
musique a le plus grand ensemble de
complexité d'harmonie et de rythmes de
tous les paradigmes de la nature la
musique est le modèle le plus complexe
le plus sophistiqué
c'est l'outil que la nature utilise pour
générer toute la diversité des protons
neutrons quark neutrinos qui composent
notre univers dans un certain sens donc
la physique l ensemble des mélodies de
la nature je voudrais a évoqué une autre
théorie très populaire surtout dans les
films de science fiction ces derniers
temps la théorie des multivers qu'en
pensez vous existe-t-il des réalités
parallèles
et bien d'après la mécanique quantique
les objets peuvent exister dans de
multiples réalités je parlais ici à
moscou d'ordinateurs quantiques des
ordinateurs qui font des calculs dans
des univers parallèles
on croit généralement qu'un électron est
un point qui se trouve un certain
endroit mais la théorie quantique voit
cela différemment et estime que
l'électron peut se trouver dans de
nombreux endroits en même temps c'est
renversant mais comment est-il possible
qu'un électron puisse se trouver à deux
endroits en même temps parce qu'il
existe dans un multi vers un multivers
d'univers parallèles et cela permettra
comme l'on pense de créer un nouveau
type d'ordinateur je suis venu à moscou
pour ça pour parler d'un ordinateur
quantique qui calcule dans des univers
parallèles
est ce là la grande percée en physique
qu'on a mentionné au début de cette
interview
nous ne croyons plus en un univers qui
est la théorie d'un univers unique
nous estimons que notre univers peut
coexister avec d'autres univers et nous
croyons que cela explique beaucoup de
mystères de la nature
il semble par exemple que notre univers
a été conçue uniquement pour rendre
possible l'existence des humains si la
force nucléaire était plus grande le
soleil aurait brûlé il y a des milliards
d'années déjà
si la force nucléaire était plus faible
le soleil ne se serait jamais formé donc
l'univers semble s'être réglé uniquement
pour rendre possible l'existence de
l'humanité
cela veut-il dire qu'un dieu a créé les
humains ouais pas nécessairement cela
signifie qu'il existe des univers où le
soleil ne s'est jamais formé et d'autres
où il a brûlé trop vite
nous avons de la chance nous avons la
chance de vivre dans un univers où la
vie est possible sans ce que vous dites
exclu l'option selon laquelle il
existerait plusieurs mois et plusieurs
vous dans des univers différents ou
parallèles parce que là-bas le soleil ne
s'est jamais formé où il a brûlé trop
vite ça dans certains univers parallèle
il n'y a pas de vie parce que le soleil
ne s'est jamais formé ou à brûler trop
vite
cependant il y à d'autres mondes qui
ressemble au nôtre où il y à des doubles
de nous mêmes quand je me regarde dans
un miroir
je me rends compte que je ne me vois pas
vraiment tel que je suis à ce moment là
je me vois tels que j'étais il y à un
milliardième de seconde
parce que c'est le temps qu'il faut pour
que la lumière haye et viennent et je
comprends également qu en me regardant
dans le miroir je vois des ondes des
millions et des millions dont deux qui
me ressemble mais qui ne sont pas
vraiment moi certaines de ces ondes vont
dans des directions différentes
ici je décide d'aller à l'école là
d'aller à la plage c'est un même moi qui
se divise entre plusieurs univers cela
signifie t'il qu'il existe un univers
parallèle où un autre moi et pas commis
les erreurs que j'ai commises dans cet
univers
c'est bien ça ou un autre univers où
vous avez fait beaucoup plus d'erreurs
et dans cet univers-là vous avez la
chance d'être ici
comment sont-ils interconnectés c'est ce
que mes décisions dans cet univers
affecte ce qui m'arrive dans un univers
parallèle dans la plupart des cas la
réponse est non en règle générale nous
ne pouvons pas entrer dans un univers
parallèle
en d'autres termes les univers vibre et
ils vibrent à l'unisson
mais ces univers commencent à s'écarter
avec le temps et il est donc très
difficile d'entrer dans un univers
parallèle car nous ne vivrons plus à la
même fréquence que les autres univers
dans cette salle il y à des ondes des
dinosaures des ondes des extraterrestres
et de toutes sortes de choses
incroyables les ondes d'un univers où
les gens n'ont jamais existé par exemple
sauf qu'on ne vibre plus au même rythme
nous nous sommes désynchronisée 2 donc
nous ne pouvons plus parler aux
dinosaures
autrement dit des dinosaures se trouve
probablement dans cette salle ça semble
fou n'est ce pas mais nous ne vivrons
plus à la même fréquence que et il est
impossible de se parler et d'interagir
de quelques manières que ce soit il n'y
a peut-être pas de moyens tangible de
communiquer avec soi même ou avec les
dinosaures mais il doit bien y avoir
quelque chose qui nous relient tous
qu'est ce que c'est c'est vrai il y a
bien quelque chose au niveau
subatomiques cela s'appelle une
intrication ou les ordinateurs
quantiques calcul dans différents
univers l'ordinateur n'existe pas dans
un seul univers mais dans de nombreux
univers à la fois c'est pour ça qu'il
est aussi puissant plus puissant qu'un
ordinateur classique qui fait des
calculs avec des 0 et des 1
car un ordinateur quantique fait des
calculs dans plusieurs univers cela peut
sembler ahurissant
cela ressemble à de la science fiction
mais c'est ce que nous appelons physique
cet ordinateur quantique pourrait-il
disons dans cent mille ans nous aider à
percer cette bulle notre univers pour
nous rencontrer nous mêmes dans une
autre bulle en univers parallèles mais
c'est concevable mais très difficile à
mettre en oeuvre
en fait les ordinateurs quantiques sont
très difficiles à créer parce qu'il faut
que tous les électrons vibre à l'unisson
et quand il était clair qu'ils se
divisent en deux univers ils ne sont
plus capables d'effectuer ses calculs et
alors croyez le ou non l'avenir de la
civilisation toute la puissance de
calcul de la future civilisation peut
dépendre de l'informatique dans
différents univers là ce n'est plus de
la science fiction
il se peut qu'un jour l'économie en
dépendent nous allons faire une courte
pause à notre retour nous poursuivrons
cet entretien avec michel kacou pour en
savoir plus sur la façon dont fonctionne
notre univers restez avec nous
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour avec me choque à
coup vous avez évoqué la physique
quantique et je voudrais qu'on en parle
de façon plus approfondie car c'est un
domaine compliqué il faut du temps pour
comprendre comment tout cela fonctionne
mais il ya une chose que je pense
comprendre oui non tu deviens une
particule lorsqu'on observe et
lorsqu'elle est observée c'est une vague
de possibilités au prince maurice donc
s'en suit que l'observation et la
puissance de l'esprit peuvent
effectivement façonner le monde autour
de vous et c'est à dire que vous pensez
à quelque chose où le visualiser et ça
devient réalité
qu'en pensez vous et parce que cela
fonctionne en 6x et bien le grand
paradoxe scientifique qui résume
vraiment ce dont on a parlé s'appelle le
chat de schrödinger qu'on enferme un
chat dans une boîte relié à un pistolet
et ce dernier est relié à de l'uranium
l'uranium relève de la mécanique
quantique
il émet un rayonnement selon les lois de
la mécanique quantique et c'est ça il
déclenche le fusil qui tue ensuite le
chat ça décoiffe yanis si vous mettez
tout cela dans une boîte et que vous ne
pouvez plus rien voir et que le chat est
il mort ou vivant et bien c'est nous
autres physiciens décrivons les choses
ainsi il faut prendre londe du chat mort
et a ajouté l'ong du chat on fixe le
chat n'est ni mort 1 est vivant et qui
le shah existent simultanément dans ces
deux états d'accord mais c'est bizarre
vous pouvez dire que ces fonds que les
physiciens sont des aliénés mais ce chat
pourrait être un électron électron peut
exister dans deux états à la fois ci les
électrons sont capables pourquoi pas les
chartes de re wildcat d'art et voilà
comment les physiciens envisagent cela
l'univers se scinde en deux d'un côté il
y a un chat mort de l'autre il y a un
chat en vie c'est ainsi que nous
expliquons le paradoxe de schrödinger
l'idée des multivers permet d'expliquer
comment les chats peuvent être à la fois
mort est en vie
c'est cela signifie de fait que les gens
qui sont morts d'un autre univers
pourrait être vivant dans un autre haye
nous ne pouvons pas leur parler parce
que nous ne vivrons plus à la même
fréquence
c'est à dire qu elvis presley pourraient
être vivants dans un univers parallèle
cela va-t-il dans le sens du dogme de
l'âme et de tout ce qui se passe après
la mort physique ici sur terre
est ce lié à ce que vous expliquez que
oui en quelque sorte
néanmoins il y à milan les philosophes
croyait au dualisme l'âme et le corps
étaient séparés et quand une personne
mourrait l'âme s'est levé vers le ciel
et le corps retourner à la terre les
gens ont pensé ainsi pendant des
milliers d'années
aujourd'hui nous avons la neuroscience
qui nous dit non non non c'est juste le
cerveau le cerveau pense qu'il y a une
âme mais ce ne sont que des neurones
aujourd'hui on revient à ce qu'on avait
il y à milan nous envisageons la
confiance numérique
parce qu'il est possible de numériser
tout ce que l'on sait de vous par
exemple vos transactions par carte bleue
vos vidéos vos interviews sur youtube
toutes ces informations peuvent être
numérisés même quand vous mourrez vos
empreintes numériques vives pour
toujours et cela va aller encore plus
loin à l'avenir nous serons en mesure de
numériser tout ce que l'on sait de nous
mêmes j'ai trouvé quelque chose que vous
avez dit de tout à fait fascinant vous
avez dit que le travail de votre vie et
est de synthétiser les lois de la
physique en une équation d'un pouce de
long et cette équation serait le dieu
d'einstein
vous êtes exprimé ainsi n'est ce pas
cela veut-il dire que vous êtes à la
recherche de dieu et que dieu est une
équation la théorie des cordes
oui qui résume toutes les lois physiques
connus peut être résumée à son tour en
une très courte équation c'est ça mon
équation la théorie de chant de cordes
pourquoi nous autres physiciens ne
gagnons pas le prix nobel
parce qu'il ya un problème il s'avère
que des membranes peuvent également
coexister avec mes cordes
donc il y a non seulement des cordes
mais aussi des petites balles des
ballons de plage
en fait notre univers pourrait être une
sorte de membrane cette théorie n'a pas
encore été exprimée sous sa forme
définitive
mais c'est bien le cas avec la théorie
des cordes elle peut être décrite en une
équation d'un pouce de long et il se
trouve que c'est mon équation
c'est ma contribution à la théorie des
cordes la possibilité de la résumer en
une courte équation mais ce qui m'a
frappé c'est que vous avez utilisé le
mot dieu ce serait le dieu d'einstein
non pas einstein disait qu'il voulait
lire dans les pensées de dieu et ce sont
là ses propres paroles vous voyez il ne
voulait pas nécessairement dire que
cette équation exprimé dieu ou que cette
équation était dieu mais que c'était la
pensée de dieu
voici comment il a formulé et a éludé la
question qu'est-ce qui est apparue en
premier
dieu où l'équation il n'a pas dit qui
étaient là en premier cependant il
estimé qu'il y avait deux sortes de
dieux qu'il convenait de distinguer le
premier est un dieu personnel qui répond
aux prières le dieu qui frappe les
philistins le dieu de l'ancien testament
il ne croyait pas en ce dieu personnel
il croyait aux dieux de spinoza le dieu
de l'harmonie de la beauté de la
simplicité
l'univers n'a pas à être beau l'univers
est simple et magnifique
vous pouvez exprimer toutes les lois de
la physique en une petite équation
ce n'est pas un hasard alors selon
einstein il existe un dieu des lois
physiques n'a pas un dieu personnel qui
répond à vos prières et punit les
philistins mais un dieu de l'univers qui
nous donne les lois physiques
en d'autres termes un législateur comme
le disait einstein
est-ce aussi votre compréhension de dieu
c'est ma compréhension de dieu nous ne
savons pas d'où vient cette équation
nous savons seulement qu'une fois que
vous avez cette équation et que vous la
résolvez vous avez des électrons des
protons des neutrinos et des big bang
des terres de l'eau et des êtres
qu'est-ce qui vient en premier selon
vous l'équation dieu je ne sais pas il
est clair que nous n'avons pas de mots
pour décrire qui est arrivé en premier
einstein aurait peut-être dit que dieu
était là en premier et que les pensées
de dieu et l équation donc que dans un
sens ce sont les pensées que dieu a créé
il a également dit qu'avec le progrès la
compréhension de la physique devenait de
plus en plus simple vous voyez nous
avons tous ces concepts physique
quantique conde particules membrane
cordes trou noir
mais il est difficile de commencer à
comprendre ne serait ce qu'un de ses
concepts comment cette compréhension se
simplifient tel hawwa vous savez j'ai
des amis qui obtiennent leur doctorat de
critique littéraire anglaise et rédige
des thèses sur shakespeare en se
demandant que voulait-il vraiment dire
par cela et je me suis dit que l'anglais
devenait de plus en plus compliqué oui
chaque année quelqu'un écrit une
nouvelle thèse sur james joyce hemingway
ou shakespeare
c'est à dire que l'anglais devient plus
compliqué avec le temps la physique elle
se simplifient de plus en plus les lois
de l'électromagnétisme qui rendent cette
interview possible s'appelle les
équations de maxwell une équations de
maxwell et longue d'un demi-pouce la
divergence du temps se relève nuls puis
la lumière en sort l'équation d'einstein
pour la gravité est un peu plus longue à
jamie v égal 0 c'est la célèbre
équations d'einstein la mecque cela rend
possible les trous noirs et le big bang
la théorie quantique est plus compliqué
il s'agit d'une page de texte mais elle
peut être résumée avec la théorie des
cordes qui est encore une fois décrite
par mon équation
c'est ainsi que la physique devient de
plus en plus simple vous avez
même souligner ce paradoxe tandis qu'en
physique les équations deviennent de
plus en plus simple les humains ont
tendance à compliquer les choses comme
il les compliqué il y à 100 200 ou 2011
wa pourquoi la vie ne devient elle pas
plus simples et plus faciles à
comprendre
si c'est le cas avec les lois de la
physique qui régissent le monde qui nous
entoure nous estimons que les lois
fondamentales étaient très simples et
pures au début des temps mais les choses
sont devenues complexes après le big
bang
le cerveau humain par exemple l objet le
plus complexe de l'univers connu dans
tout l'univers avec toutes ces galaxies
on n'a rien trouvé qui pourrait se
rapprocher de la complexité du cerveau
humain
il y à 100 milliards de neurones
chaque neurone est connecté à dix mille
autres neurones notre cerveau est
capable de produire des milliers de
milliards de penser cela signifie que
les interactions humaines sont
extrêmement complexes les lois
fondamentales des atomes sont simples
mais la façon dont elles forment le
cerveau humain et les modes
d'interaction entre les gens est une
question extrêmement compliqué
j'aimerais craquer façon à un autre
sujet une étude britannique au canada
italienne a formulé ce que les
chercheurs croient être la première
hypothèse fondée sur des observations
prouvant que notre univers n'est qu'un
vaste et complexe hologramme donc que
tout ce que nous vivons nous est projeté
depuis la frontière de l'univers c'est
bien ça la théorie des cordes considère
l'univers holographique comme un produit
dérivé
figurez-vous un hologramme il a deux
dimensions il est plat mais quand vous
pointez sur lui un rayon laser vous
recevez un front d'onde en trois
dimensions si votre globe oculaire se
trouve ici vous voyez trois dimensions
c'est comme ça que par exemple des
fantômes et toutes sortes de créatures
peuvent être en trois dimensions à
disneyland et dans d'autres parcs
d'attraction comment est ce possible
c'est une plaque en verre avec un
hologramme dessus projeter des faisceaux
laser et vous obtenez une image en trois
dimensions
nous pensons que notre univers est très
dimensionnelle parce que nous comprenons
la longueur et la largeur et la hauteur
la théorie des cordes nous dit que ils
n'ont l'univers à 10 ou peut-être onze
dimensions
il y à d'autres dimensions que nous ne
pouvons pas visualiser on comprendre
cela penser à un enfant je passais
beaucoup de temps à san francisco a
regardé les poissons à nager dans un
jardin japonais
les poissons vivent dans deux dimensions
ils peuvent nager à gauche à droite en
avant en arrière ce qui est au delà de
l'étang leur est totalement étranger et
qu'ils ne peuvent pas visualiser le
monde dans en étant à seulement deux
dimensions
et puis je me suis dit que s'il y avait
un poisson scientifiques ils se diraient
pas ridicule la troisième dimension
n'existe pas il n'y a que deux
dimensions tout le monde le sait les
temps est tout l'univers
et puis j'imagine un enfant saisir un de
ces poissons scientifique le sortir de
l'étang le faire passer dans le monde
d'en haut que verrait ce poisson il
verrait des êtres tridimensionnel se
déplacer sans à jouarre une nouvelle loi
de la physique et des êtres respirant
sans eau
une nouvelle loi de la biologie et puis
j'ai imaginé que j'avais relâché ce
poisson dans l'étang et me suis demandé
comment il pourrait expliquer tout ça
aux autres poissons
j'étais dans un univers parallèle je
suis allé au delà de l'univers
j'ai vu des créatures qui peuvent se
déplacer dans une troisième dimension et
les autres poissons lui aurait dit tu es
font aujourd'hui nous sommes comme ces
poissons
nous passons toute notre vie en trois
dimensions
nous déplaçons de l'avant vers l'arrière
à gauche à droite vers le haut et vers
le bas et nous pensons que c'est tout ce
qu'il y a que la réalité est tout ce qu
on voit des rien d'autre vous espérez
alors que quelqu'un va venir vous
arracher à cet univers et vous dire
coucou regarde ce qui se passe là bas il
est imaginable qu'un jour quelqu'un
d'une autre dimension d'un autre
multivers ou d'un autre univers bull
arrive dans notre univers pour nous dire
regardez il y à là tout un univers un
univers parallèles dont les dimensions
dépassent celles que vous connaissez et
aimez
merci beaucoup aux professeurs kacou il
est tout à fait fascinant de vous parler
nous remercions également l'hôtel le
plaza de moscou font de nous avoir
permis d'organiser cet entretien merci
c'était un plaisir
[Musique]